hey everyone welcome back to my round
five recap video of the gibraltar battle
of the sexist tournament in this game i
played none other than grand master
maria music from ukraine
she is a former world women's champion
uh one of the highest rated players
playing in this event with a few day
rating of 25 39
and i believe she is number six in the
world for women players
uh so i knew it was going to be a tough
opponent
but
i came prepared
and we walked into
what started as an open sicilian
and if you guessed from the title i did
play a surprise move here
which
caught her perhaps a little bit off
guard
now the main move here by far which has
been played millions upon millions of
times
is c takes d4
which enters the kind of main open
sicilian position where black has a lot
of options
but
a secondary move which is completely
playable for black
is knight to f6 and i looked up the
statistics of this move and it's played
in about three to four percent of of
games in the masters database
so uh it's a playable move
and normally this move just transposes
back into an open sicilian after knight
c3 takes takes
and i was ready to go into this position
however when i played knight f6 maria
began thinking for uh for longer than
expected she took about say five to six
minutes
in this position
and
didn't play
knight c3
um now i'm not sure why because if i
took took and then played that f6 knight
c3 is the most common move it's possible
that she wanted to go into something
like f3 uh which is one of the main
reasons to play knife six in this
position is to avoid the f3 line it's
also possible she was preparing maybe
queen takes d4
but
i didn't quite find out what her her
main preparation was in the event that i
if i took on d4
so after i played knife six she played a
move which i knew was playable here is
bishop to b5 check
definitely not the most common move
and we ended up going into a variation
which is
very rare
i'm checking the stats here
it's been played in in just over a
hundred games
and after bishop d7
takes takes
we trade the pawns takes
i takes e4 cd6 knight g6 this position
has been reached 32 times in master
level play
and one small tidbit i did have this
position on my computer screen the
morning of the day that this game was
played so it was part of my preparation
although i didn't prepare super
extensively here i just knew that the
engine gives approximately equal
and it's very playable for both sides
so
we continued here uh following opening
principles she castled i played knight
c6 knight c3
and then i took a bit of a think because
it's a question how black completes
development
i was very tempted to castle queenside
to try and make the game really sharp
and exciting
and then eventually go for some kingside
attack
but i concluded that's uh it's very
risky given that i don't have a c pawn
and
like can develop very naturally with
bishop to f4
so i was then thinking how to develop my
dark sport bishop and there's really two
ways to do so there's
e6 and bishop e7 and there's g6 and
bishop g7
and i decided to go for kind of the more
dragon style put the bishop along the
long diagonal
and the reason why i didn't play g6
first in this position is it walks into
queen d4
so it's important to play knight c6
first control d4
and then play pawn g6 and here we
continue bishop f4 bishop g7
queen e2
so a very natural move
getting ready to play rook d1 and
pressure my knight on d6
i went ahead and castled here and then
she played rook ad1
so at first glance it looks to be a
little bit
awkward for black because my knight on
d6 is pinned
it's attacked twice
and my queen is just aligned with the
white rook
so
in attempt to resolve the issues i
played the move queen f5
which i think is one of the strongest
moves
it gets off the d-file
and hits the bishop puts the queen on a
very active square also pressures the c
pawn
and i wasn't really worried about white
winning a pawn here uh queen f5 is a
upon sacrifice
allowing bishop takes d6 takes d6 and
rook takes e6
but
i thought i would have at least a few
options here maybe the simplest is
bishop takes c3 b takes c3
and move like queen a5
hitting
this and this
and i spent a bit of time calculating
this and thought i should be completely
fine here after queen c4 rook c8
and the extra pawn for white isn't too
meaningful
so
she didn't take on d6 instead she played
knight to d5
which is a very confrontational move
of course targeting e7
and making it so i can't play rookie 8
because then there's like c7 with a fork
so uh the center was beginning to get
quite messy just with
all the minor pieces in the position
having influence on the various squares
i could draw more arrows here but might
as well
show the next move i played pawn e5
uh creating even more kind of chaos in
the center
i'm now attacking the bishop
but i'm leaving my knight and undefended
and
in some sense i am subjecting myself to
tactics
and i will admit here i
kind of overlooked her next move
now i was aware that okay white has some
tactical ideas
but i didn't quite realize that her next
move
actually works tactically she played the
move knight takes e5
and
this is where things get really messy
but it's also the beginning of things
simplifying
so the point of knight takes e5
is that
this knight on c6 is tied down to
defending e7 if i take on e5 too soon
with the knight then
i get forked and oh no my queen
um so after she took on e5
i took with my bishop
and here it looks like if white takes on
e5
with the bishop
then i can play rook e8
and even though i'm down upon
temporarily
white is a little bit struggling with
this pinned bishop on e5 and the move
like knight f6 doesn't quite work
because queen takes f6 and there's a pin
and after takes takes takes
i win c2 this should be fine for uh for
black i believe
um so instead of going into that she
played the move that i only realized
after she took on e5
after bishop takes e5
she doesn't need to take with the bishop
she can actually take with the queen
and this is a very easy move to overlook
because
it just looks impossible my knight is
hitting the queen but the point is if i
take the queen then she forks me and
this is a very good transformation for
white if i play king g7 takes takes
takes
uh things simplify i'm just down upon
here black is much worse
so
didn't go into that
after she played queen dixie 5
i just took back with my queen and this
is a slightly better version for black
because after takes
takes
white does win back the piece after
knight to e7 king g7 and rook takes u6
and all of this happened in the game so
a ton of trades uh the chaos has
settled a little bit
but we get into a position where i have
compensation for the pawn
uh for a few reasons first of all this
knight on
e7 is a bit exploitable and also the
pawns on the queen side are potential
targets i have ideas of knight c4 to hit
the rook and the pawn
but here i decided to start with the
move rook f2 d8
it's possible that i had a the better
option perhaps work 88 was a bit a bit
more precise to keep the option open of
rook fe-8
but the point of rook ft8 here is that i
want to get a situation
where if she takes
i would take back and the knight is
trapped on e7
and i think black would be very close to
winning here after king f6
and white would have to um
to be very very careful not to lose
knights on e7
so instead of playing rook takes d8
she played the move rook d to d1 and now
it's up to me to try and prove some
compensation
for still being down upon
and i grabbed initiative played knight
c4 hitting the pawn on b2
she played b3
and then i bring my knight back to b6
so at first maybe it looks like i lost a
bit of time
moving my knight twice
but the point is now i'm controlling the
d5 square
which is really the only getaway for the
nylon e7
and in order for white to
resolve the problem of the knight she
has to go for the idea of c4 and knight
d5
which happened c4 was played king f6
and knight d5 check
and then the nice thing for me is that
after takes takes
the pawn and d5 is
it is an extra pawn for white but it's
also a very clear weakness in the
position
and i have a simple plan of
getting my rooks to the d-file playing
king e5 and trying to target the pawn
um now not exactly this happened as
we're going to see but
i thought we were reaching a position
that
should be very close to equal because
extra pawn
i didn't think is is so
strong for white however the game does
continue and we're gonna see there's
very much a fight left to be played
i started with rook to d7
the reason for rook d7 and not rook d6
is to preserve the g6 square for my king
which could be relevant in some lines
there's other lines where i want to just
have the rook defending my pawns on the
seventh in case white goes for some
eventual counter play
and here she played rook to d4
i responded with rook 2 c8
i did consider rook a to d8 but
i thought that after rook d1
if i try and attack the pawn here
threatening rook takes d5
she has annoying move f4 and then my
king would either just have to move back
to f6
or move to d6 where it prevents my rooks
from attacking the pawn
so
even though i can attack the d-pawn a
few times it's really hard to win
and i figured that i might as well just
control an open file try and get my rook
to c2
she played rook fd1 i brought my rook to
c2
and she played the very simple move a4
so
keeping the pawn defended i play king e5
now
she played g3
i play king d6 and i was still feeling
very fine here um again even though i'm
down the pawn
i didn't quite see how white makes
meaningful progress
but as we're gonna see she uh she was
very resourceful in the position
and found
some interesting ideas to keep the game
going
she played the move rook 1 to d3
play rookie 7 ideas of eventually
targeting the second rank maybe even
going for rookie 5 and rook c5 to get a
situation where i have three clean
attackers against the d5 pawn
but then she played a move which i think
is very strong it's pawn to g4
and turns out white does have
a pretty clear plan in this position
is to swing over the rook from d3 to h3
and attack the pawn on h7 which can be a
very clear weakness
on top of that she might also want to
play g5
and just use one pawn
to fix three pawns on the king side
so g4 is a really nice positional move
for white
and i was beginning to sense that the
position isn't so
simple
and i still have to play accurately to
hold on i went ahead here and played
rook to e5 which is a multi-purpose move
it
pressures a d5 pawn but also supports
either f5 or h5
in the event that the rook comes to one
of these files
so she played rook f4 here
and i responded with f5 so here we're
going to see some trades
she took
took
takes and takes
i thought the more trades that happened
especially the trades of pawns the
closer it would be to just drawing the
game
so uh i i was okay with this
transformation
and here she played king to g2
and then i realized
uh oh
i have to be careful because if i allow
the king to come too far in
then
i might just be losing
especially if the kingdom's f4 and f5 is
a big weakness
and i don't really have time for rook c5
this is a move of course i want to play
right away just to win the d5 pawn
the problem here is
white's king activates really quickly oh
i can play king g3
and i can't get away with taking on d5
because after takes
takes
this is a winning king pawn ending for
white
simply because white's king gets too
active
after king f4 king e6 king g5
white's going to win the h pawn and
eventually win the game here
so i was well aware of that
and in a position like this especially a
rook ending
uh the concept of prophylactic play
is really really important and for those
of you that don't know what prophylactic
means it just means preventive play
so the thought process for me in this
position
is to ask myself what does white want to
do
and how do i stop it
so it's very clear white wants to
activate the king and once we know that
the answer to the second question is
actually pretty simple
i want to get my rook to e4 if i get my
rook to e4 it cuts off the king prevents
any annoying counter play from lights i
play rookie 2 here which i think is the
strongest move so that if king f3
rook e4 and it would be very difficult
for white to make progress from here
given that the king is completely boxed
out of the position
and white's rook is also tied down to
the pawn
so we didn't enter that line uh instead
of king f3 she played the move rook to
h3
which
i was actually happy to see because
after rook h3
it's a signal that we're going to be
trading more pawns
i started with a move rook to b2
um now pressuring b3
and also creating a situation where she
can't move her king to the third ring
because then i take with check
and even get a winning position
so she took on h7
i took on b3
winning back the pawn and defending my
b7 pawn
she played rook f7 and i played rook to
b4 and she played a5 here so saving the
apon
i play rook b5
and here she played h4
and now it's clear that white has a just
an easy idea to push the h pawn
and make a queen
and i do have a decision to make
which pawn to take
ultimately i decided to take on d5 here
the point being is that if she takes on
b7 i would take on a5 and this should be
a pretty easy draw given that i defend a
pawn and it's
king rook in two against king rook and
two h pawn doesn't scare me
but uh instead of
white taking on b7
she continued to push h pawn
and here i do have to be careful because
h pawn is
just three moves away from queening
and uh i don't want to allow light any
like weird promotion tricks or tactics
or anything like that
so i decided to play the move
f4
which looks very logical it attacks the
pawn opens the fifth rank here i'm just
trying to simplify as much as possible
she continued here with h6
and then i took on a5
so pawns are
continuing to come off the board she
took on b7
and this is where we reach a critical
moment
uh rook takes b7 was moved 41 so we each
got an additional half hour on the clock
i had a lot of time to think here
and i did take a lot of time i probably
spent 15 minutes on my next move
um just because we're so deep into the
end game
it's clear white is still the one
playing for a win and the pawn is
dangerous white has ideas of king f3 to
win the pawn so i have to be really
really careful here
and when i played my next move i thought
i had calculated
everything
and i'll go ahead and show i played the
move rook to
h5
my idea was that i would just put my
rook on h4
abandoning my a7 pawn
and i thought the rook on h4 would just
hold
the whole king side together keep an eye
on h6 it would prevent the king from
doing any damage because my f-pawn would
always be defended
and then i would have a very simple plan
and bring my king in and i didn't think
white would have any chances of winning
this position just because things are so
so simplified
so we reached this position
i had about 15 ish minutes left on my
clock
she took on e7
i confidently played rook two h4
and this is where
to my horror
she played a move which i had completely
overlooked
this is a the second kind of big
surprise of the game
i managed to surprise her on move three
but she surprised me on move 43
and for some reason her next move
completely escaped me
and when she played it i very quickly
knew that i was in some trouble
so here comes the time if you're
watching this and
you want more time to think feel free to
pause the video
and find the best move for white
i will say it is white to move and find
the only winning move
it does bring me some pain to look back
at this position
but it's also just a really instructive
moment
and shows perhaps one of the differences
between
an international master and a
grandmaster like maria
um who's able to find these resources
very late into the game
where perhaps we're both a bit tired
exhausted from playing for several hours
but
as we see her endgame technique was
incredibly sharp and the move she played
here is rook 2 a3
it took a moment for things to sink in
but
yeah black is now in big big trouble
because white has a threat of rook h3
and i can't take the pawn immediately
because
rook a6 check
would then win my rook
and the problem here is my king is just
a little bit too far away
uh from just saving the position
i really want to play king e6 here
the problem is after rook h3
if we trade rooks
i could win the h pawn
but
white can win the g pawn and this would
just be a losing king pawn ending
with white's king well in front of the
the past f pawn
so
didn't go into that
again i took my time here and was trying
to find any possible resource to put up
resistance
and i was really calculating every
option imaginable and the move i ended
up playing here is f3 check
it's a tricky move it's an attempt to
bait either the king or the rook to take
my pawn
if rook takes pawn then i can take on h6
this would be a draw
and if king takes pawn then rogue h3 and
i win the rook so white definitely
doesn't want to do that
um unfortunately after i play f3
she
doesn't take the pawn she plays king g3
very strong move
hitting my rook
again laughing at the fact i can't take
the pawn because rook a6
so i put my rook on each one
and now she
plays a move which uses the same idea
as
earlier when we saw rook a3 the whole
idea was to get behind the pawn
here she plays rook to a4
which i'll admit i didn't see coming but
it makes so much sense in the position
and of course she saw rook a4
and she likes it because the rook now
wants to come to h4
and i have all the same problems as
before but this time my f3 pawn is
definitely going to fall
so
i play rook g1
she took i play rook h1 i was really
trying to create a situation where
i'll have a chance to bring my king to
h8
what just happened there
unexpected
code
let's cancel that
um unfortunately the
uh
the teleportation doesn't exist yet my
king
can't teleport to h8 um she played king
g3 threatening rook h4 again
i was annoyed i checked
now she plays king h2
and here my rook can no longer defend
from behind
it has to go in front of the pawn i'm
after h7 rook h8
rook h4
white achieves the basically dream
position where my rook is completely
completely stuck
if i ever move it light will queen
now the only piece left that can move is
my king
and we're going to see me get into
zugswang very very quickly after i move
my king in
she delivers check on h5 i play king g6
and she plays king to g4
now i did have one really hopeful trick
in the position
that
after i played the move king f6
i was really hoping she would play f4
king g6
f5
king f6
and if white's not careful here
and plays a move king f4
thinking that black's just in zuma's
wong it looks like my king has to move
back light will move forward
uh turns out there is one saving move
here for black and this is another great
kind of puzzle moment if you don't see
the move for black feel free to pause
the video
it is black to move and draw
the move being rook takes h7
and uh there is a really nice stalemate
potential in this position
of course she did not even give me the
chance to to set that up
and instead of playing f4
she played rook to h6 just forcing my
king back to the seventh rank
and after king g7
i keep having to move my king
she plays rook h4 move my king she did a
little bit of time wasting but uh
white can kind of just torture me here
because
i i only can move my king and once i
play king f7
she brought her king to h6 and now that
white's king defends upon white's rook
can start hurting me
and come even more alive after i play
rook a8 she played rook f3
king e6 king g7
i gave one more check
king g8
and here i threw in the towel and
resigned
so this was a very heartbreaking game
especially because i thought the game
was just heading towards a draw out of
the simplification in the middle game
but here we saw the persistence of a
very strong grand master and maria
moozichook
and
all it took was
one blunder for me to lose a game if we
go back to the critical moment
the only drawing move here was king e6
which looks very logical an attempt to
just walk towards pawn
now it still would have been tricky
and
even though it's easy to just look at
the engine and think this is an easy
draw after king to f3
i still need to be really really precise
turns out there's only one drawing move
again for black in this position which
is rook to h2 so i will say after this
tournament is over i'm gonna have to
study this end game a lot more
extensively
and just end games in general too it's
so so important to
um to minimize mistakes laden endgame
because one mistake and the whole game
can be over
and this game was especially painful
because i spent
over four hours fighting
holding on against a very strong player
and uh i still lost and it was all due
to
um to a blunder very late in the game
but that's one of the lessons in chess
and hopefully i can
come back stronger and hopefully this
will make me a better player
so
that about does it for the recap i hope
you guys enjoyed it hope you learned a
thing or two
and now it's time for me to sleep
and also prepare
i'm recording this on the rest day
tomorrow's around six and i'll be
playing against another strong player
marie sabag from france
so stay tuned for more videos and i will
catch you in the next one